E
>> AUGUST MEANS SPECIAL
MONTHLY TREAT THAT PINK BOX OF
DOUGHNUTS, JESSICA ANDERSON
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
BRILLIANT BIG BOX MARKING
OKAY, SHE'S HERE TO TELL US
WHAT'S UP DOC. RIGHT WAY AND
WHAT'S QUE PERFECTLY REON CUE.
>> SO WHAT THAT MEANS
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A BUDDY
INSPIRED DOUGHNUT THIS MONTHRE.
IT IS A CARE OKAY DO IT WITH
CREAM CHEESE FROSTING ALNGL
WRINKLED WITH REHIS HIREREFAVOR
CARROTS. OKAY SO BEFORE WE GET
TO THE REST  FOF THE DOUGHNUTS
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
DON'T WORRY. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND SHOW HOW TO MAKE THIS ONE
T
JUST GOING TO LET YES.
>> SO LET'S HEAR YOUR DONUT
DECORATING SKILLS THEY  ARE  SO
YOU GOYOT TOYO GET LIKE THAT CO
MOTION AND THEY 'RE JUST A
LI
TTLE BIT  REOF ROTATIONTA. REOK
GOT THIS GIISRL, ISISISISREYOOWW
OWYOU OWJUSTOW LIOWKE RE
>> SHE'S GOT IT REITYOITU GOITT
HAVE THE ROUGHLY YEAH YOU GOT
TOP ITTO TOALL YOU DON'T DODOWO
DISAPPOINT CARROTS ON TOP YOREU
HAVE GO UP TOP YEAH. STREET
VERY BUGS BUNNY APPROVED RIGHT
WHAT I DO BEST EATING
DOUGHNUTS. SO I'M GOING TO TRY
I DO THAT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
CARE BEARS THAT'S WE     CARE  E
BEARS ARE BACK THIS MONTH IN
AUGUST, WE HAVE BED TIME
THERE. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE DOING A
LINEUP EVERY SINGLE MONTH CARE
BEARS BEAR TEACHER. SO WE THAT H
TIME BEAR THIS MONTH NEXT
MONTH IS GOING TO BE SHARE
BEAR WHICH OF ALL THE KIDS
GOING BACK IN SCHOOL IN
SEPTEMBER.
>> GOOD TIME TO SHARE AND THANEN
OCTOBER IS TENDERTE HETEART TET
SURE TO COME IN CHECK OUT OUR
MONTHLY CARE BEARS DOUGHNDOUDODO
DOTHERDOE DODODOFRIDAY 3 SET A
OUR AND YOU DON'T WANT NTTO NTMT
OUT BEFORE IT GOES AWAY NEXT
MONTH. AND WE ALSO HAVE
AWESOME URGE TO SO I WANT
POINT OUT THAT WE DO HAVE CARE
BEARS MERGE SO NOT ONLY CAN
YOU TASTE THE TASTY DO NOT CAN
WHERE YOU CAN WEAR AND
REPRESENT AND HOPE REREREWITH CE
BEAR HOW TONY YOU SAID RETHIS I
JUST FOR AUGUST, CORRECT, 3RD
OWNER OF THE MONTH FOR AUGUST
THE YOU DEFINITELY WANT TO
COME IN TRY OR CARROT CAKE
IT'S SO DELICIOUS AND TASTY
THIS IS AN AMAZING MAKE SU